Y AT ANY REPUBLICANS WHO JOINETH
INVESTIGG DE
OULD L
>> Reporter: ANDREW SAID IZ , AN
IT WAS AORTOS  CNTBE VERY CLEAR
MMITTEE S.WH SINIS, IT WASSHOCKO
EEER PI,ANU, VMcCARTHYNDRE
S COMMITTE
IT.or
THBOUT WHERE
THISOMTTAND D ABOUT TAKIE JO
FOR KEVIN McCART.LL UNCLE
WILLE
CO'ST OF DIFFICULT
POSITION, BECAUSE THE SPEAKER O,
ULTI VPICKS
N'F McCAS OPN PLAYEDL RIOTS, P
REPUBLICANS, UDING MODERATES A
TO AOFEPE
MEMBERS TODAY, IT WAS CLEAR,
VIRTUAY NONE OEM E  TTHEY VIEA .
ING THOU
CROSS WI WIT
ULTEHOOSE TO ARTHY'S.E MOVE FORT
NAME SOME CHOICES TO THE
COMMITT DL
HEARING WITH CIT POLICE
OFRS
EXPERIENCES OM
THEY WILL GOEY GE CHAIRMAN OE I
BENNIE THOMPSON, SAID THISOU
GO OUGH NE
NOT GOING TO B
THE END OF T.ASKED M,L YOU CAN
RM
HE SAI'SOS
LSO OPO CALLING IN E REPUBLICAND
McCARTHY.UARY 6.COULD INCL
THANK YORY>>> DSY
PAIDEGY FOR VIRTHYKS FOR TAKINTE
ITLICANS IN RTOUSUPPORTEA
IN THE HOUSE VOTED TO .
HEEVEN AI GAONEAEMANDSED IN THAF
>> THIS IS ACOMMITTEE, SUBPOENA
AND I DISAGREEIT
AM A PAID
ADVISEBUT I DON'T  STUFF.
BUT THISA  KIN
ISAN COMTTLD POLITIC
VIOLENCE.
INCOLLEASTEVE ISBALL FIELD.
WHUS ON JANU6?THRELE-
ATS KNOW THEA
2022 TO
M THIS UP FOR OSES A
VER AN
AGAIN.
NOW THEY HITTEE
WHERE NANCY PELOSI COU --
HE WANTED 2 LETTER, HE ADDED IL.
THEN YOU DONOO
ONHE CAPITOL, EVENN YOU INSIDE
FROM THE VERIN
FIRST OPI E EQUAL,
THEY WOULD B CHARGE OF THE
ARE NOW,HE BASICALLYE INH ISN
GE OF THE PROCESS.
IT'S POLITICAL TAT
YESTERDAY,INGTON POST"ID M IN O
HAPPENINE LI DID AON
S IL
THANK
YOU FOR STATING AT YOU WANT
KEVIN McCARTHY CLEARLY
ORT OF -- S NOT TRUE N
BECAUSOKR
EROOKING FOR
OF INTEREST REMEMB, HE WNG FORTF
AND HE MAY CALLED S E CALL WITP
VRAS
>>E' IT
REPEATING -- HE'S SPOKENUT THAT.
ISTHEATER. BENGH
I COUL
>> ANSWE AM.
THS T POLICS
BENNIE TMPE OUT QUESTI.
TOHEF THE YEARWE DOING THIS
NEED TO KNOWBOS A ISSUE, AND
BY THE WAY, ASAM
IF DUNN NUARY 6, WHICHCTS NO ON
ARE GOING TO RUNN SECURING THEB
>>NU
ONE'S IN THIS COUNTRY?S COMMISS
TO AFFECT OP LIVES>>LDAVANSWERS
TO- KE!
AN ONGOINGE OR H THREAT ACCORDIH
POBEARING.I  YOUHAT
BENGHAZI AND THAT CO
LET'FIND THE TRUTH
THE TRS US?AT CMI
VE RHEE CRTE
ANON.D INIG T
BACK TEN MEMBERS ORE AY SHOTEAI
IN CONGRESS THAT AOONG
THIS.
TH P
HAS CREATE
AND REPUBLICANS ARE RIGHT   RL .
96% CONSERVATIO TELL YOU
Y  WORRIEDZ CHENEYPO?
AND HET HE CLIP AR TODAY.ADE CL
YOU OWEN Y
BY THE CER.AND IT'S JUST TELLG
COMMITTEE WITH THIS CRAT
GOG  YOU AABLEL KEVIN ISOI
THTH
SOMEWHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DO
THAT>> IT COULD HAVE BEEN
BIPARTISAN.
>>T
TIME AGO IF TH HAD AGREED
HAVETHAT K
THAT.
IN'R PARTISAN WORLD.
EVIS